the u.s economy is in much worse shape
than we previously thought the bureau of
economic analysis just revised the q1
gdp data and is not looking good
previously it was reported that the us
economy shrank about 1.4
on an annualized basis in q1 but now all
of a sudden that revision is showing at
least 1.6 contraction in the gdp data
from q1 what that means is that the us
economy is doing even worse than they
previously told us and if we go ahead
and we look at the actual charts we can
see that the us economy hasn't done this
bad since literally the start of the
covet pandemic back in 2020. as you can
see here q1 there was an economic
contraction q2 there was a massive
economic contraction two straight
quarters of economic contraction that
means it was a recession of course the
economy came roaring back once the
government and the central bank stepped
in with all sorts of monetary and fiscal
policy and stimulus now that we got that
economic contraction in q1 of this year
all lies are on q2 data if we get
economic contraction in q2 that'll be
two consecutive quarters and it'll mean
that we're in a recession now whether
the q2 data actually is negative or not
there's many people who feel like we're
in a recession regardless of the actual
definition what that means is that the
psychology of consumers is changing the
psychology of investors and consumers is
worth paying attention to because
ultimately that psychology will
eventually show up in the data in the
future
this data like the gdp data is actually
backwards looking it tells us what
already happened but as we've seen the
federal reserve they've made their
intentions very clear they believe that
assets and inflation have gotten too
high and that they are going to destroy
demand if they are successful in
destroying demand the hope is that
inflation will come down but in order to
bring inflation down and destroy demand
it means that we're gonna have some sort
of contraction and so the psychology now
is people are preparing for a recession
and in some way we actually may manifest
a recession because of the feds telling
us that they're gonna destroy demand
what does everyone do they start
hoarding cash they stop spending as much
and they stop investing as much that's
where you see asset prices coming down
that's where you see inflation hopefully
will start to come down but it means
that a recession is on the horizon and
if they cannot actually find the soft
landing which i don't believe that they
will it'll mean that we went from the
kovid 19 pandemic to historic inflation
all the way to a recession a nice little
round trip in about two into two and a
half years it's not exactly the economic
stability that consumers or investors
want in an economy we got a lot of work
to do and keep your eye on that q2 data
if it's negative it'll mean that we're
in an official recession if it's not
it just means that that psychology is
likely to play out in the data q3 q4 and
into 2023 there is a massive complex
machine at play here and what we are
watching is not only a bad situation
play out but we're also watching the
intervention and manipulation of the
economy because the central bank and
elected officials they have to have some
need to feel in control and the only way
they can do it is step in and try to
destroy demand in these moments i don't
know what's going to happen but this
feels very uneasy and uncertain and i
think that's what you're seeing play out
with consumers and investors alike they
want cash they don't want to get
overextended they're going risk off and
that likely is gonna show in the gdp
data at some point hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time